[Music]
hello there well you are watching the
press preview first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive in the
next half hour we'll see what's making
the headlines with journalist and author
rachel shabby and political
correspondent at the press association
jerry scott they will be with us from
now until just before midnight
well let's start by having a look at
what's on some of those front pages uh
we begin with the observer which leads
with criticism of the prime minister
after he compared ukraine's resistance
to russia with brexit telling the tory
party spring conference that ukrainians
want to be free to do things differently
the sunday times has the same story it
adds that in an interview boris johnson
reveals he told china that backing
russia is like picking the wrong side in
the second world war
the express meanwhile has the russian
military's announcement that it has used
a new hypersonic missile for the first
time in combat
the sunday telegraph reports boris
johnson is privately frustrated with the
chancellor's apparent resistance to his
plans to increase the number of nuclear
power plants in britain
and the star has a story about what they
claim is a haunted hotel in britain
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers uh while you
watch us
well as we said we're joined tonight by
rachel shelby and jerry scott so let's
get straight into those papers and let's
begin uh with this story that's on the
front of the express
now putin unleashes invisible
missile this is the hypersonic missile
capable of carrying nuclear weapons that
was fired it's the kinsale missile that
has been fired for the first time
it is a worrying new development uh in
this war does it mark do you think uh
jerry scott a new a new stage
well i think it does but i don't think
anyone's really surprised i mean it's
terrifying this missile can travel five
times the speed of sound no
kind of modern um you know anti-missile
technology that we have seems to be able
to stop it but
um defense officials western officials
have been saying that really we are
expecting putin to escalate his methods
because this invasion has not gone to
plan for him he was expecting a very
swift takeover of keeve that president
zolensky would argue arguably out of the
way by now um so he's getting more and
more desperate and using even more
indiscriminate methods in this conflict
and we've seen that in the various uh
bombings of civilian buildings of uh the
theater and it just seems like it's
going to get more and more bloody and
it's an awful situation
richard shabby do you agree with that do
you think this is
a sort of continuation of what we've
seen this slow escalation or is this uh
because given the fact that the west
can't stop these uh weapons does that
show that actually if and when putin
decides he wants to take the upper hand
perhaps he still has it
yeah i think i i agree with with jerry
in the sense that it is uh moving into
this phase of a war of attrition
essentially so we can see russian forces
now are doing very similar to what um
what they did in syria actually which is
to just surround
um cities and
besiege civilian populations just
bombard them
um from the air
absolutely grotesque grotesque way to
carry out the war and you know besieging
civilians in that way
but that is that is what putin seems to
be doing not least because um i think
it's right to say that this hasn't gone
uh according to plan
uh for putin or certainly not according
to plan a
um
the russian army seems to be
really un under prepared
the strategy doesn't seem to have been
that great and meanwhile i think the
ukrainians have surprised not just putin
but you know more widely
with the opposition that they've been
able to put up not least because there's
been such a civilian effort to resist
that appalling russian invasion but also
because the ukrainian army actually
seems pretty well equipped even before
um western nations started to channel
ever more sophisticated weaponry
to ukraine to resist that invasion
we already seem to be able to
resist russian advances and so we are
now in this period of of attrition
where
you know it's very hard to see
how this doesn't lead to more and more
brutal deaths and the russians are
taking a heavy hit as well although you
know we're looking at civilian
population being attacked by russia in
ukraine but you know obviously the only
way out of this is the negotiation um
and it's just a case of
how fast that can come to pass the
telegraph certainly saying in terms of
what you're talking there about the
russians taking a hit as well the
telegraph uh talking about 2500 bodies
russian bodies uh taken to belarus under
the cover of darkness which is quite uh
well quite a depressing image that these
uh these soldiers
will essentially be hidden from their
families until i don't know when uh
let's let's move on because we've we've
got lots to get through the observer and
the front page there fury greets prime
ministers claim that ukraine fight is
like brexit this uh inter this about
boris johnson so comments yesterday that
the struggle for freedom that is
currently going on in ukraine is similar
to the struggle for freedom that
happened during the brexit vote what do
you make of that uh jerry scott
but it's not going down well that's for
sure whether you look at that
internationally or at home um you've had
uh kevin barwell lord barwell um who of
course worked for theresa may saying
that it's a ridiculous comparison not
least because uh ukraine applied to join
the eu um you know you've had uh donald
tusk saying that it's uh nonsense as
well i actually think this is quite a
rare misstep from johnson in
this uh conflict because in ukraine
certainly it sounds like he is very well
thought of i interviewed a previous um
ukrainian prime minister just the other
day who said that boris johnson is the
country's number one
ally and sajid javid at the torrey
spring conference yesterday was saying
that you know he's that he's been told
that orion is being called a hero in
ukraine so
um it is a misstep it doesn't seem to
have gone down well and it would be a
real shame i think for the leadership
that the uk has shown in this to be
ruined by the prime minister trying to
play to the home
jerry i'm going to interrupt you because
i want to just bring rachel uh in
quickly on this before we have to go to
our break rachel do you do you agree
there with jerry
i i do i mean to me this reminds me a
little bit i'm not saying that boris
johnson is trump this seems quite a
trumpian move in the sense that it's
just a
stupendously ridiculous
thing to say
and it it immediately provokes a
reaction you know everybody is triggered
by it as jerry says both domestically
and internationally and then that's what
we're talking about instead of you know
other more worthy subjects um as jerry
said it has been roundly condemned not
least um
you know by eu leaders and it's you know
worth pointing out that actually
uh ukraine applied to join the eu
uh the minute that russia invaded
ukraine yeah absolutely and there is a
sense uh certainly from donald tusk the
former president of the european council
saying uh i still remember the
enthusiasm of putin and trump after the
referendum boris your words offend
ukrainians the british and common sense
uh right well let's uh leave that for
now we will be back after the break
coming up we'll be taking a look at the
front page of the sunday telegraph its
headline johnson frustrated with sumac
over
nuclear find out more about that after
the break
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now are the journalists
and author rachel shabby and political
correspondent at the press association
jerry scott uh we are going to go
straight into our papers i know we're
short on time in this uh in this part so
let's go straight to the front of the
telegraph uh johnson frustrated with
sunak over nuclear uh jerry this seems
to show again and we've had rumor of
this before some sort of rift between
the treasury and number 10.
yeah it's fascinating this kind of
latest skirmish in the battle between
the two and yeah this is really all part
of well all manner of challenges for
number 10 whether that's kind of getting
away from the kind of reliance we've had
on russian energy
and the whole west needing to do that
but also to tackle this cost of living
crisis which we know is coming down the
road with national insurance
contributions going up and energy bills
rising boris johnson seems to want to
have a real push on nuclear but the
chancellor rishi sunak and his officials
are saying actually
these plans aren't fully formed yet so
how can we cost them and back them and
there's a really interesting detail in
this report actually which seems to
suggest that rishi sunak hasn't shared
his spring statement and what might be
in that with number 10 which is a very
blaring brown if you ask me but um it
does point to some rifts between the two
neighbors and uh not a happy family at
the moment yes certainly that was
fascinating that a refusal to share
those uh those notes uh let's head
straight over to the express and this uh
headline axe threat to pno over mass
sacking this the government last night
reviewing its contracts with piano after
800 ferry workers was sacked without
notice uh rachel i mean this the
government we know has contracts with
the ferry uh operator to transport goods
what are the chances they're actually
going to uh do anything about those
i think that's a really interesting
question as you say the government uh
uses pno it has just under 11 million
pounds worth of contracts to ship goods
uh the labour party has estimated that
38.3
million in government funding has gone
to piano since 2018.
um
and maritime units have suggested that
the government goes even further it just
revokes pno's license uh to operate so
there's a lot of pressure on the
government following this absolutely
appalling roundly condemned sacking but
it's worth pointing out you know what
whether the government is actually
capable of doing this let's not forget
that just last year the government
roundly opposed uh a proposal to
prevent um companies from fire and
rehire policies uh which is the sort of
thing the pno has been pursuing one in
ten employers employees have experienced
fire and rehire since 2020 or the
effects of it
um and so you have to wonder how much
the government is winning a government
that has you know really bashed sort of
employment rights that would allow
employees to stand up to this sort of
behavior you have to wonder how likely
they are to do it but it's also worth
saying that this precedent set by p o
needs to be
there needs to be some pushback
otherwise what's to stop other companies
going ahead and doing the same things